throwback to the the hentai episode uh
the one thing that i did like about that
one thing that you picked
even though i i didn't particularly
which one uh the one that was like the
edo era japanese oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
i was like that's the one
i was at least at least like the fact
that they took three episodes to build
that [ __ ] up before yeah
you know yeah i like it when they tease
you yeah like
you know because you know you can go on
[ __ ] pornhub
and you can you can skip two minutes in
you're already at the [ __ ] meat
yeah yeah i like it when they make you
wait for it something yeah
it's like it's like you're making me
feel like these characters are worth it
you know what i mean
yeah cause when they immediately put
their pants down and he's [ __ ] two
other women i'm like i'm not investing
he's like you've lost me
it's a no for me yeah i like i like
being able to wait to see
the best girl you know i'm impatient
yeah i'm patient
oh you know i'm i'm also impatient
sometimes i'm just like let's just skip
to episode five and let's just see
okay like and then but like i feel like
the best times
is like when you know there's a reason
to turn the next page there's there's a
reason
to like watch the next episode like it's
it's new it's like metal gear solid the
best is yet to come
you know don't consider the plumber
turning up
a riveting story yeah worth me turning
the [ __ ] page yeah
i think that's the one thing that at
least i can appreciate about the durgin
is that you can you can
kind of almost if there's a story you
can kind of read it in your own pace and
yeah get the feel for it that you want
i i can i can i can respect that i wish
that i could read it
and then the moment the [ __ ] starts
i'm like turn on the hand-tied version
yeah well
this one actually does have a hint yeah
i was about to say this one does have an
entire
say that is it bad it sounds bad it's
queen bee ah
i'm gonna watch it all right i i'm
actually
curious about your opinion i'm actually
curious about your opinion now that
you're going to go from like a dojin
to an adaptation of that direction
because you enjoy it because there's
another one
by us that i was debating on whether to
recommend called nude speech
which is i love the nudist speech the
hentai it's great yeah yeah that's
that's
the same guy yeah i like that yeah
that's like and the the dojin version is
like
one of my favorites and also kaho's
favorite oh yeah we like bonded over
that but like i was like
do i recommend it but like pizza humming
just has a better story in my opinion i
like the story a lot yeah and when i
like started
with nudist beach i was you know when i
watched that originally i was like you
know what
you know what you can you watch
something you just know this is popular
yeah yeah
i'm like i know this one i don't know
anything about hentai or dojin community
and what the [ __ ] they get up to but
i've watched that and i'm like
i bet this is famous as [ __ ] just from
watching this i'm like the [ __ ] is too
who adopted new to speech again
queen bee no it wasn't it was good
adaptation though was it i thought it
was queen no i swear i watched that and
it was good
i don't i don't think it was queen bee
really i swear it was a good
adaptation let's see but i gave this one
um what did i give this one uh are you
saying nine out of ten
really i i genuinely i dig the story
honestly that's
really surprised me i thought you would
hate this one cheers to that cheers to
that
look at us
[Applause]
we are we are two for four i think two
for four two for four right now we're
slowly converting him
we're slowly converting you